no I find it very interesting is that
YouTube said that you knew this $20,000
goal was kind of like why this was at
the high end of the spectrum you know
and you said that you too kind of like
going after the impossible and then sort
of like really pushing it can we talk
about setting setting that particular
number goal because i think that's
that's often one of the things that
everyone sort of struggles with it's
like okay i think i want to make this
project and i think i'm going to want to
try to try crowdfunding and setting that
goal can be so tricky because you just
don't know you don't know how to size it
up so can you talk about the
twenty-thousand-dollar gold yeah so I
think our original plan um was to do a
second season of our web series and when
we ran the numbers for that we were
going to originally run a crowdfunding
campaign for that but we were going to
set that at maybe 10 to 12 and you know
when looking at the numbers of what what
we expected and hope to get where we
could reach um we thought we thought
that was doable then we decided to to
change it up and do it as a feature um
and so nothing as far as our resources
change but it but the budget change and
so we set it at a at the minimum point
that we could do production of the
future so that's how that's how he came
to that number so that doesn't
necessarily even cover all of production
but it covers enough that we could still
find a way to get production production
route get it in the cam so that's how I
came up with that and I think you know
like he said you know our original
thought was okay maybe 10,000 for for
the the second season of the web series
and you know when we did the first one
we didn't have any budget at all I mean
we had a camera and a lot of interested
people and a lot of drive and and you
know that's about it and you know when
we looked at our final product we were
we were proud of the experience and that
we had done it him had spent so many
countless hours doing it but you know
getting to do it a second time I mean
that's
really unique opportunity to be able to
work with the same people and kind of
see them grow having seen them grow over
the year and like what else to bring you
to the table and even myself like I'm
I'm kind of new at this you know because
he he's always been doing this but it's
not until recently that his goals became
my goals as well and so you know I I am
I had a lot more to bring with myself as
well so you know we talked about a lower
number but it's like that's not we
didn't want to make the same mistake as
the first time you know where we're just
having a very ambitious project where
you can't get it reasonably shot and
it's not what it looks like or it's not
what you want it to look like and then
so I think you know we had like that was
actually at the minimum number that we
would need and you could supplement the
rest with you know our own income or you
know take a loan here and there or
whatever but you know we can make up
that small difference that we needed to
get to our term full budget but um but
any lower than that you know if we had
set at twenty-five or if we had set it
at ten I mean we're still looking at you
know trying to raise another 10 15 and
and you know who knows where that would
have put us in then and our goal with
this film was to to make a good film
like she said with the first season on
the web series you know we had no budget
Lee we hadn't no not a lot of production
value um we didn't want to make another
we didn't want to make another project
that was good given the resources we
just wanted to make one that was good
period um not like well that was good
considering what you didn't have her
that was good considering this or that
or that just you know something that was
good
you